well I'm joined now by Andy bottner
who's a senior advisor at independent
women's forum and also a friend of Brett
Kavanaugh hello to you and department
thanks very much indeed for being with
us this afternoon here on Sky News as a
friend of Brett Cavanaugh how did you
feel watching him last week before the
Senate Judiciary Committee well it was
thank you for having me this morning
this afternoon it was just it was very
difficult to know Brett and his family
as my family has for the last several
years it was very difficult to watch him
go through what he did last Thursday but
I will say that he has tremendous
strength and integrity and I think that
this situation this very political
chaotic circus that has engulfed our
country the last couple weeks should
come to a close on Saturday afternoon
and we're very confident that Judge
Cavanaugh will become a Supreme Court
justice do you think that he is fit to
become a Supreme Court justice has he
displayed the right qualities I mean
many have criticized his demeanor before
the Judiciary Committee last week for
being over emotional he interrupted
senators who turn questions about
drinking back onto one of the senators
he talked about revenge on the behalf of
the Clintons was that the behavior
befitting of a man due to be appointed
to such a position well I I would say
this Brett is he's a human being he's a
son he's a husband he's a father and I
think what has been lodged the
allegations lodged against him have done
great damage trying to tear down his
reputation his very integrity and I
think what we saw last Thursday was a
human being the personal coming out from
behind that justice or that Judge robe
brett is someone he's had a very
impressive professional even keel
professional career over the last
20-some years and I think the last two
weeks just brought him to a point where
he was fighting for his name for his
family yeah and he that you're
describing him there as being
professional and on an even keel because
his temperament has been brought into
question hasn't it and we've had more
than 2,400 law professors from across
the political spectrum and I suppose
that's important because this has become
very partisan but saying that the lack
of judicial temperament that he
displayed would have been disqualifying
for any court let alone the highest in
the land well I disagree with that I
think that this has been a very
calculated political campaign from the
beginning of July and I think that all
of these allegations were brought to
bring the pressure increasingly up on
Brett and I think last Thursday when he
spoke he defended himself as a man a
husband a father and his son and frankly
I just find it quite ridiculous that
you've got senators sitting there
passing judgment because to me that was
just the height of hypocrisy
we have senators in there talking about
drinking at age 16 or 17 they should be
ashamed it was really quite an
embarrassing moment I think for many in
the Senate and certainly for those of us
in the United States watching our
elective what about the pressure also
then on Christine Blasi Ford being put
before that committee well that to me is
very heartbreaking I think as I've said
before that Christine Blasi Ford any
survivor of sexual assault domestic
violence needs to be heard but just
because an allegation is made they don't
automatically need to be believed there
still needs to be evidence fact-checking
and opinions drawn conclusions made
based on our system of due process based
on rational thinking and I find it very
in so
Waltzing is a woman too to be told well
you have to believe a survivor because
she's a survivor or says she is and
she's a woman I still am able to make my
own judgments and in this case when
weighing the weight of the evidence
according to what dr. Ford brought up
there's just not credible corroboration
I I just don't believe her
some though of questioned the veracity
of the FBI investigation though because
it has been so shortened because it has
been so restricted well I just find that
laughable as well because as we see here
it's a calculated campaign this was
something the Democrats were wanting
demanding a week ago we need an FBI
investigation well they got it they got
it and they don't like the results so
now it's no surprise well it wasn't long
enough it wasn't thorough enough I you
know this is not something that is
surprising to those of us here nothing
would be good enough because at the end
of the day what they want is to stop
judge Cavanaugh for gaining that seat on
the Supreme Court and I just hope and
I'm very confident now that that will
not happen we believe that he will be
seated and he will be a Justice of the
United States Supreme Court I just hope
for Brett and his family he is able to
wake up after the end of this weekend on
the sunrise side of the mountain